تشكل اله الساز تراثا موسيقيا في تركيا
فهي معشوقه الفنانين وكثير من الهواه
يفضلونها ولا يقتصر الاهتمام بها على
الفنانين فقط فهناك رياضيون وكتاب
وسياسيون ايضا برعوا في العزف على هذه
الاله الموسيقيه اوضح مثال على ذلك رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الجديد
يلا
تلقى اغاني ابراهيم كانين رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الجديد صدى واسعا عند الجمهور
في تركيا فهو عازف ومغني محترف وكاتب
ومتخصص بالفكر الاسلامي والفلسفه شغفه
بالموسيقى والغناء لم يمنعه من احتراف
السياسه والعمل الامني فهو احد المستشارين
السياسيين والامنيين لاردوغان في السنوات
الماضيه
عملت
لمده خمسه اعوام هو شخصيه متنوعه له عده
نشاطات يهتم بالفن وبالفلسفه والادب عمل
كثيرا وبشكل متصل مع رئيس الاستخبارات
السابق هاكانفيدان وكان من ضمن فريق
النخبه الامنيه والسياسيه للرئيس اردوغان
انتقاله الى جهاز الاستخبارات شكل مفاجاه
للكثيرين لكن المقربين منه ومن عمل معه
يؤكدون انه على درايه
معظم الملفات الامنيه لذلك لم يكن قرار
تعيينه مفاجئا لهم
منذ عام 2018 وهو يعمل كرئيس للجنه سياسه
الخارجيه والامن في رئاسه الجمهوريه وهي
اللجنه التي عملت فيها مستشارا له وان لم
يكن له توصيف رسمي لكن السيد كالين كان
المستشار الاول للرئيس اردوغان في قضايا
الامن وسياسه الخارجيه ايضا كان وكيل
الرئيس في اداره لجنه الامن القومي
في استحقاق ابراهيم كالين الجديد لن يعزف
على اوتار السياسه وتقلباتها فقط بل هو
مطالب باداره ملفات امنيه اطلع عليها في
سابق عمله كمستشار وناطق اعلامي باسم
الرئاسه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات